So begins the end.
For Darkseid
I've never seen a being this strong.
Maybe one he's back
I spent a lot of time trying to divide us
I made a promise to him on his grave
I need to bring us together
there are enemies coming from
far away they serve an old power
this world is divided
no protectors here. No
lanterns. No kryptonian. It will fall in his name
I have turned worlds to dusk
all of existence shall be mine
I have a second chance i am not gonna waste it
they said the age of heroes would never come again
fighting the devil and his army
In Hell.
I don't care how many demons he's fought in
how many hells he's never fought us united
it's time to stand fight
the time
is now
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new justice league snyder cut trailer video
zack snyder dropped a brand new one because
the movie is coming out this week and they
lifted the embargo on a lot of the early reviews
and reactions so i'll break that down as well
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i will be doing all the
regular videos later this week once it actually
drops on hbo max and internationally and people
actually have a chance to see it if you do live
outside the united states and you're not sure
where they're actually going to be dropping the
movie in your country i believe the official
accounts for the movie tweeted out some links a
while ago where that's actually going to happen
because it's going to be a little bit different
depending on which country you live in but per
zack snyder it's coming out simultaneously all
over the world so nobody's going to have to wait
to watch it i'll talk about the new footage first
then i'll talk about the review stuff it's all
really good stuff though all what you want to hear
it is the most version of justice league and even
better than some of zack snyder's other dc films
but it's one of those fascinating stories that
i don't know if it'll ever happen again because
the story of them making the movie is almost as
interesting as the actual movie itself the movie
that was made three times first by zack snyder
then by some other guy who will not be named
and then by zack snyder again but the new
trailer starts with the footage of darkseid in the
flashback war that we've seen before and voiceover
from closer to present day when his communicating
with steppenwolf through the mother boxes so
begins the end thematically you can see why they
chose to cut some of the dialogue in the trailer
this way because the way they talk about it
being the end the wait is over it's time to come
together it's all about them finally releasing the
snyder cut like the wait for the actual snyder cup
movie is over love that they were able to work
in that classic comic book line for steppenwolf's
character for darkseid we get a much bigger
version of the scene of him walking through
the throne room of his ship here this is obviously
decide on one side and then granny goodness on the
other this is when he has become full-blown dark
side because he's wearing the classic armor or the
zack snyder version of his classic armor you see
the omega symbol on his chest just like in all the
cartoons the comics the animated movies then you
get the wonder woman voiceover where she's talking
about steppenwolf actually where she says i've
never seen a being this strong maybe one when she
refers to darkseid so she's talking about darkseid
being more powerful than steppenwolf because
there's a whole bunch more steppenwolf in the
snyder cut than there was in the theatrical cut
does a much better job of setting up his character
and making him feel like a real credible threat
really badass in a way that the theatrical movie
did not you get way more of his backstory too so
you understand his relationship with darkseid much
better but the way they cut the scene is with them
standing in superman's tomb and this is obviously
after he's been resurrected and they're getting
ready to throw down with him just hyping up the
idea that superman is also potentially as powerful
as darkseid and if you didn't hear all the theme
music in the movie is also done by junkie xl he
was originally going to do the theatrical score
but then when they brought joss whedon onto the
movie joss whedon brought in danny elfman and even
though i love danny elfman he has some of the most
iconic movie soundtracks of all time one of the
most iconic batman movie soundtracks of all time
but i think that junkie xl's score
suits the justice league snyder cut much
better it's much more in keeping with the tone of
what zack snyder was wanting to do with the movie
then you get the scene of batman standing on top
of the batman tank that's inspired by the frank
miller tank from the dark knight returns he talks
about bringing the justice league together i spent
a lot of time trying to divide us now i need to
bring us together he's referring to the events of
batman v superman where he was basically fighting
superman for most of the movie he talks about the
promise that he made on superman's grave to save
the world to bring everyone together because
he had learned of this threat that was coming to
earth in batman v superman that was all about the
flash time traveling to warn him to save lois lane
i've already talked about the alternate storyline
that he wanted to do in the sequels where he was
going to have this love triangle between batman
lois lane they were going to have a kid together
and then superman was going to come back lois lane
would eventually go back to superman batman would
later sacrifice himself later in the sequel so he
would dive you know twist on superman dying early
in batman v superman eventually batman would die
probably never going to wind up seeing those maybe
they'll turn into a comic book at some point but
i've already talked a little bit about some of
the other deleted story lines and plots that would
have happened in the justice league sequels so
i'll probably do a bigger video about that after
the movie comes out this week the really cool
thing about that too is if you haven't seen jim
lee was actually talking about it on his twitter
jim lee did the storyboards for the justice league
sequels pitch that zack snyder was giving to the
studio he talked about drawing these super tall
storyboards having to use this giant stepladder
so that he could do it all and doing it with a
sharpie marker the reason why we found out about
this recently in the last week or so is because
they have a special museum exhibit for the snyder
cut itself with a bunch of the characters costumes
and obviously these storyboards supposedly there
is an unseen storyboard that zack snyder kept for
himself so we'll never know what was on that
unless he actually tells us but we actually
know how justice league 2 and justice league 3
would have gone down had they been made you get
a lot of familiar scenes from the characters
there are a lot of people that have said
that a lot of the movie does play out similarly
to the plot of the theatrical cut it's just that
there's way more story lines and way more moments
with all the characters providing more context so
overall it winds up being a much more enjoyable
experience but i'll get into that in a second too
then they have the scene with them hyping up the
mother boxes them all activating because of the
signals from the boom tube steppenwolf coming in
when wonder woman says they serve at old power
she's talking about the mother boxes themselves
because the mother boxes are sentient you see the
new version of steppenwolf creating his lair looks
very different from the theatrical cut him uniting
the mother boxes together in the unity so to speak
as he called it i've already talked about a lot
of the anti-life equation storyline that zack
snyder had planned for the sequels and it sounds
like we're going to see a lot of easter eggs for
that during the snyder cut because you also see
martha kent's eyes light up red just seemingly
while she's standing in the doorway there that
probably is tied to the anti-life equation you get
that same speech from steppenwolf where he talks
about the no protectors this world is divided
no protectors this world will fall like all the
others as you see them cut it with the footage
of the flashback war zeus the other greek gods
going up against darkseid this version of green
lantern in the flashback scenes is Yalan gur he
was actually the green lantern of earth thousands
and thousands of years ago the really cool deep
cut easter egg is that when he wound up dying
in the comics his body was actually incorporated
into the green lantern's starheart which then
became the basis for alan scott's green lantern
battery and his ring we get a brand new scene of
darkseid charging the field and that big dark side
war flashback with him running out the back of his
ship jumping down to fight them they cut down his
speech just a little bit with him talking about
turning a hundred thousand worlds to dust and when
he's talking about taking back what was taken from
him he will take the rest of the universe just the
idea that he needs the three mother boxes in the
anti-life equation in order to do that i talked
about that in my last video it's basically like
his final boss form upgrade gaining the power of
the anti-life equation to manipulate that so that
he can enslave the entire universe all at the same
time instead of having to fly around doing one
planet at a time i've already made the thanos
infinity gauntlet comparisons in my previous
videos and for those of you that are wondering
who's more powerful darkseid or thanos in the
amalgam comics dc and marvel did cross those
characters over so you can actually read that
storyline but it was a long time ago when they
did that the scene of the blue energy covering
the entire earth seems like it's associated
with the earth cracking over like it's when they
unite the mother boxes so it might be happening
during that big wonder woman explainer when she's
explaining the dark side war flashback and how
he's conquering all these different worlds or when
one of the characters are just trying to explain
who darkseid is and what he does but really what
he's doing is he's flying to these different
planets and using them as really glorified mining
operations to fuel the engines of apocalypse war i
made the game of thrones night king reference in
the last trailer to the white walkers reference
because that's kind of what he does with his
parademons he converts conquered enemies into
more parademons if you watch the animated movie
justice league apocalypse war a lot of that movie
feels very similar to the beats of the justice
league sequels that zack snyder would have done
in that you see a version of justice league
characters that he's taken over with the anti-life
equation and turned into his new furies see these
really hardcore looking versions of wonder woman
and the other characters but the people that made
that movie are completely different completely
separate from zack snyder he didn't have any hands
in making that animated movie you have the scene
of superman coming back in the black suit that
we've seen in all the trailers most of the reports
are that there isn't quite as much superman as
you would expect given the four hour run time so
even though there's way more superman than there
was in the theatrical cut more for his storyline
his scenes are still a relatively small portion of
the film compared to the total 4-hour run time the
character that really gets the upgrade in terms
of brand new scenes extra story lines is a cyborg
character and he definitely seems like he shines
during the snyder cut in a way that he was almost
relegated to the background of the theatrical
cut so if you see ray fisher going crazy with
excitement this week because of the snyder cut
that's why because he's kind of like the star
of the justice league snyder cut this scene of
the amazons at the campfire here seems like it's
actually them witnessing a vision of darkseid's
armies coming this isn't them actually watching
this happen in present day it's them using this
fire to create this vision that they're seeing
this scene a dark side probably one of the biggest
things people were talking about the past couple
of days because it was one of the other tv
spots but you see darkseid using his omega
beams in atlantis underwater so you get to see
him full-blown action i've talked about this in
other videos but the whole thing with him in the
flashbacks is that he has not become full-blown
darkseid yet so he doesn't have the omega force so
i'm not expecting to see him use this in anything
other than the present day or the flash forward
nightmare scenes you get a longer scene of cyborg
watching his father sacrifice himself steppenwolf
standing behind him there coming for his mother
box we get a couple more scenes from the final
battle here against steppenwolf more superman more
wonder woman more aquaman more that big speech
from cyborg's father trying to rally them now
is the time to stand now is the time to fight we
get another new scene of the joker in that flash
forward nightmare scene if you saw some of the
other pictures that zack snyder was posting too
you can actually see that it seems like he's
wearing the gotham city police department vest
but he's also wearing a bunch of gcpd badges on
that vest too most of the consensus in the early
reviews is that the third act is just amazing like
the whole film in general is much better than the
theatrical cut so no big surprise there we all
kind of expected that but overall within the
movie the third act is the strongest and i think
that plays a lot on zack snyder's strengths as a
filmmaker he is really good with his visuals and
really big action scenes which is basically with
the third act of most of these types of movies are
so you talking about like big avengers end game
third act scene is on the scale of something like
that but if you did see any big easter eggs that
i didn't talk about during the trailer footage
just write them below in the comments and when
you do have a chance to see the snyder cut just
post all your reactions on the video like i said
i'll probably do a longer full review video later
this week after the movie is actually released for
everyone and more easter egg videos talking about
the new scenes and what's different also really
big reminder falcon winter soldier episode 1 is
going to be dropping the day after the snyder cut
releases so i'll be doing videos for that every
week for all the episodes just like i did for
Wandavision make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of that is going
to be a crazy week in the best possible way while
you wait for everything click here for my brand
new falcon and winter soldier trailer and click
here for that other really big justice league
snyder cut trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!